[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat le sénat parle aux
territoires dans quelques minutes vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct la
conférence de presse de gérard larcher
le président du sénat qui s'expriment
devant la presse quotidienne régionale
et les télévisions locales
l'occasion quelques jours après le
congrès de l'assemblée des départements
de france et avant celui des maires de
revenir sur le malaise profond des
territoires ce malaise profond ce sujet
nous allons parler justement avec
patrick le lidec bonjour bonjour vous
êtes chargé de recherche cnrs professeur
à sciences po paris
je le disais les relations entre les
territoires l exécutif sont extrêmement
tendues est-ce que vous jugez déjà qu'il
ya une part de volonté de
reconcentration de la part de l'exécutif
aujourd'hui depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron alors
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
décisions qui ont été prises peut-être
en matière budgétaire avec effectivement
les contrats qui normes l'évolution de
la dépense qui sont un facteur
effectivement de mécontentement mais je
pense que cet élément la touche
principalement les grandes collectivités
locales qui sont dans le périmètre de
ces contrats on sait qu'il ya à peu près
330 collectivités que ça touche donc ça
ça n'est pas probablement le motif
majeur de ces motifs
voilà c'est pas le seul motif
certainement pas et certainement pas
vis-à-vis en tout cas des mères dont on
attend le congrès je pense qu'il ya
aussi des facteurs plus politique qui
explique cette situation
le facteur politique le plus évident
c'est que la république en marche à une
très faible implantation pour le moment
dans les collectivités territoriales
elles ans dirige à peu près 20 très peu
et donc sa voix n'est pas entendue au
sein des associations d'élus et donc
c'est plutôt une jambe de l'ancrage
local de la république en marche qui
explique aussi cela il le fait qu'il ne
soit pas vaine exécutif
oui bien sûr puisque en fait il voulait
les dirigeants des principales
associations d'élus en tout cas les
trois principales arf adf arf font
partis d opposition nationale et donc
leur stratégie politique c'est plutôt de
cliver sur ce plan et de d'amplifier en
quelque sorte la grogne des territoires
amplification de la grogne des
territoires un certain nombre de mesures
concrètes qui ont aussi été prises par
l'exécutif
on pense aux économies demandées aux
départements et puis des mesures dont on
a beaucoup entendu parler
la limitation à 80 km/heure le coût des
aides sociales les coupes dans les
emplois aidés tout ça ça a été des
mesures quand même qu'ils ont été autant
de petits déclencheur alors bien sûr il
ya ya ya ya ya à la fois si vous voulez
les décisions qui ont été prises
et pour un certain nombre d'entre elles
d'ailleurs des décisions qui ont été
prises en réalité par la majorité
précédente qu'ils y viennent à
s'appliquer avec un certain un certain
délai et puis bien évidemment des
décisions qu'ils ont prises est
également un contexte
et je pense qu'encore une fois cette
situation particulière elle est la
situation politique j'entends l'absence
de représentation dans les institutions
élues dans les principales au moins
puisque ce qu'on observe aussi c'est que
le positionnement l'assemblée des
départements de france de la dcf pardon
et de france urbaine n'est pas tout à
fait le même que celui de on parle
souvent des grandes associations d'élus
qui sont vent debout effectivement mais
voilà voilà donc le mieux le monde
territoriale est effectivement plus
impunis renseigne plus divers et donc
c'est précisément cette comparaison
entre les positions des différentes
associations d'élus qui fait apparaître
le poids du facteur proprement politique
dans le dans le positionnement des
dirigeants des associations d'élus
puisque si seulement les mesures
objectives était en cause tout devrait
être sur la même ligne
or on voit bien qu'elles ne le sont pas
certaines contestent en tout cas
davantage que que d'autres après je
pense qu'il ya aussi un contexte
politique qui est celui d'un
affaiblissement du président de la
république et donc dans un contexte
d'affaiblissement du président de la
république parce que les sondages
mesurent une impopularité croissante
il est également logique que les
oppositions face en quelque sorte monter
les enchères sur un certain nombre de
réformes à venir
à cela le gouvernement a tenté de lâcher
du lest déjà il ya eu des mots le 16
octobre
emmanuel macron qu'il ya eu des mots
pour les territoires et puis la semaine
dernière des annonces du gouvernement
soutient au département sur deux
préoccupations majeures que sont les
allocations individuelles de solidarité
et puis la question des mineurs
étrangers non accompagnés ça ça compte
et c'est un marché vous le disiez ou et
bien les départements continuent à dire
mais ça ne suffit pas oui mais mais en
même temps si vous voulez voilà c'est un
c'est un premier pas en tout cas qui a
été fait je pense que un des éléments
qu'il faut avoir en tête pour comprendre
aussi cette volonté du chef de l'état de
renouer en quelque sorte le dialogue est
assez lié aussi
à la perspective des élections
européennes et à la nécessité dans
laquelle le président de la république
se trouve d'entendre ses alliés
politiques du côté à la fois du modem et
d'agir qui eux ont un ancrage
territorial très très bientôt
et donc effectivement si vous les 7 7
cette stratégie d'élargissement des
alliances qui est lié en quelque sorte à
la base rétrécie de la république en
marge tels que la mesure les sondages a
conduit effectivement à une plus grande
prise en compte des aspirations des
chefs des grands exécutifs locaux parce
qu'elle est relayée à la fois par le
modem et par agir dont on a vu
d'ailleurs qu'une place particulière
leur a été faite au sein du nouveau
bâtiment
voilà voilà donc donc c'est le sens un
peu je dirais de des évolutions récentes
et du repositionnement de l'exécutif
vis-à-vis des associations d'élus avec
notamment 1 jacqueline gourault qui
connaît très bien la question des
territoires et qui maintenant à la tête
d'un grand ministère de la cohésion des
terrils c'est aussi probablement pas par
hasard que sébastien lecornu ancien
président du département a été aussi
nommé comme secrétaire d'état pour
accompagner cette évolution parce qu'il
peut dire aussi à l'adf je suis des
vôtres donc donc c'est quand même on
sent de ce point de vue là une volonté
de de désamorcer des détentions pour
autant on n'est pas complètement certain
que ces tensions vont disparaître bien
merci beaucoup patrick le lidec pour
votre éclairage car nous allons tout de
suite prendre et bien la direction de
cette conférence de presse de gérard
larcher qui s'exprime donc sur cette
question des territoires partenariat que
cyril viguier co producteur et
présentateur de territoire d'infos sur
public sénat a mis en place il ya
maintenant plusieurs années
ce partenariat est assez unique dans le
paysage audiovisuel français c'est un
atout pour la chaîne parlementaire
public sénat
et naturellement donc pour le sénat qui
est l'assemblée des territoires
je les ai déjà dit mais un journal
régional c'est très important pour la
vie des territoires la vie quotidienne
de nos compatriotes au fond vous prenez
le pouls des lecteurs vous contribuez à
leurs informations et vous êtes des
acteurs de la cohésion des territoires
je suis en train de mieux mesurer le
poids de l'implantation des 40
télévision locale diffusées sur la tnt
elle couvre 70% de la population
française
4 millions de téléspectateurs chaque
semaine
souvent financées pour partie par des
collectivités territoriales elle assure
différentes missions de service public
elle valorise les initiatives locales
elles sont le reflet de la population
française dans la diversité
je répondrai donc à vos questions à vous
dans la salle aux journalistes et
directeurs de chaînes qui seront en
direct de leur siège à epinal perpignan
saint-etienne brest et fort de france
l'actualité de ces derniers jours a
démontré à quel point l'automne et va
être placé sous le signe des territoires
président de la république semble avoir
entendu le malaise des élus est dit
territoire je me réfère à ses propos du
16 octobre
je les cite la transformation du pays
exige de s'appuyer sur toutes les forces
du progrès de la réforme
nos associations nous élus locaux et en
particulier nos mères qui seront les
premiers porteurs de la république du
quotidien fin de citation
si en effet urgence arty c'est la
relation avec les élus locaux
c'est que le malaise est plus profond
qu'il n'y paraît parfois et que
l'actualité nous démontre une nouvelle
fois que rien ne peut se faire sans
l'adhésion de la france des territoires
les maladresses et j'utilise ce mot
volontairement du gouvernement étaient
nombreuses la volonté de concentration
du pouvoir et même parfois paru
caricatural elle s'est terminée par
l'appel de marseille où pour la première
fois les trois grandes associations
d'élus se sont retrouvés autour du même
mot d'ordre les limites de l'acceptable
été dépassée pensent et décident et
planifiée à paris c'est une erreur des
décisions qui tombe dans vos sans
concertation avec la brutalité d'une
technostructure bien souvent coupés des
réalités d'un territoire que cette
technostructure observe plus qu'elle ne
comprend quelques exemples mais nous y
reviendrons la coupe dans les emplois
aidés sans concertation préalable
c'était l'été 2010 est une suppression
la taxe d'habitation sans compensation
et remplacement clairement défini encore
aujourd'hui le coc exponentielle des
aides sociales
alors qu'on demande 13 milliards
d'économies au département là aussi les
décisions prises sans concertation
souvenez vous du débat sur les 80
kilomètres à l'heure sur les routes
qualifiées de secondaires et même un
plan pauvreté indispensable préparé sans
concertation avec deux acteurs
essentiels les départements et les
communes
et bien sûr cette décision
d'augmentation brutale des taxes sur
l'essence le gazole et le fioul
domestique sous couvert de favoriser un
objectif que nous partageons la
transition écologique
au fond on le voit ceci ne sert qu'à
alimenter les caisses de l'état est ce
qu'on a pensé aux 70% des français
notamment dans les territoires qui
utilisent leur véhicule pour travailler
c'est l'exemple du contre message la
majorité sénatoriale proposera lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
la suppression de la hausse de cette
taxe sur les carburants mais je vous
invite à vous reporter au journal
officiel de la séance
du 24 novembre 2017 il ya un an
tout était dit sauf une prescience
on pensait que les bonnets sera encore
rouge et on n'avait pas imaginé que les
gie laisserai jaune j'ajoute enfin que
la transition écologique que sujet est
bien le projet de loi de finances
rectificative va montraient plutôt une
baisse des crédits pour l'année 2018
si le président de la république nous
dit et je le crois avoir entendu l'appel
de marseille
et pourtant les trois associations
avaient déjà envoyé une première alerte
c'était le 12 juillet on ne participant
pas à la conférence nationale des
territoires la semaine dernière le
gouvernement à rennes a accordé un
soutien aux départements concernant deux
préoccupation très importante
les allocations individuelles de
solidarité les mineurs étrangers non
accompagnés
mais comme l'a dit le président des
départements de france les d'urgence est
bienvenue mais les problèmes de fond ne
sont pas réglés le grand test va venir
je ne suis pas dans l'est de la france
le grand test va être le chantier de la
refonte de la fiscalité locale ou ne
sera pas question de jouer les uns
contre les autres mais ensemble et tout
simplement de s'en tenir à ce que le
président de la république a dit au
congrès des maires l'an dernier sur le
territoire
l'accroissement de la démission de maire
de conseillers municipaux et
significatif on peut pas le traiter avec
condescendance légèreté c'est un signe
d'alarmé qui touche à la vitalité de
notre démocratie locale je le dis
souvent la commune c'est la petite
république dans la grande
au sénat nous avons consacré de nombreux
travaux réforme territoriale menée ces
dernières années mis en place une
mission permanente de contrôle et de
suivi des réformes territoriales
elle tient d'ailleurs à colloque cet
après midi même
au sénat cette mission elle a décidé de
se concentrer sur les enjeux de
l'intercommunalité des liens avec les
communes en abordant les enjeux
subsidiarité de participation des mères
aux instances de décision des
intercommunalités mais aussi capacité de
communes d'exercer pleinement les
compétences de proximité nous pensons
communes rurales mais pas qu'à elle avec
un mot la subsidiarité est là aussi dans
le cadre de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales tra semblait
fait des propositions pour rénover les
conditions d'exercice des mandats le
courte mais place maintenant aux
questions
place aux interrogations qui me seront
posées soit par vous même soir par les
télévisions locales
c'est me semble-t-il la meilleure façon
d'engager le dialogue d'une assemblée
qui entend avoir un lien avec le
territoire
merci monsieur le président de nous
avoir convié à à prendre la parole dans
cette conférence de presse la presse
quotidienne régionale mais aussi les
chaînes de télévision locales
je m'appelle jean brun je coordonne le
réseau via qui regroupe 22 chaînes de
télévision locales en france
ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on a
tout de suite retrouvé dominique renaud
qui dirige bien vosges télévision epinal
oui monsieur le président merci de merci
de nous recevoir chez vous vous venez de
reparler de l'appel de marseille vous
aviez déclaré qu'il avait fait bouger
les choses
alors c'est vrai que les représentants
des collectivités territoriales souhaite
cette république du quotidien mais il
souhaite également que cette république
soit véritablement décentralisée vous
avez parlé des détaxes parce que c'est
vrai que pour agir dans les territoires
il faut des moyens il faut des moyens
financiers avec une taxe d'habitation
qui va disparaître
la taxe sur le foncier bâti qui risque
cette fois pu très bien si elle va être
laissé au département où elle si elle va
partir
vous le sénat entend être un véritable
partenaire bien sûr dans la réforme de
la fiscalité locale or la question des
sables est ce que les discussions ont
commencé sur cette évolution de la
fiscalité locale et comment faire pour
redonner une autonomie financière à ces
collectivités sans lever de nouveaux
impôts premier principe les
collectivités territoriales ne peuvent
pas être des contributeurs à l'effort de
redressement du pays
elles ne sont pas là pour s'exonérer
d'ailleurs sous le quinquennat françois
hollande c'est d'abord à près de 70% la
contribution des collectivités
territoriales le second des sujets c'est
qu'en fait nous n'avons pas commencé à
réellement discuter et dialoguer
parce que nous en sommes au sixième
scénario de remplacement vous rendez
compte de la taxe d'habitation
c'était dans le projet du président de
la république on en prend acte mais
aujourd'hui les collectivités thériault
elles n'ont aucune certitude
est-ce qu'on joue au bonneteau
transférant du foncier bâti
départementale aux communes et aux
intercommunalités la seule méthode c'est
la méthode du dialogue de la
concertation
et cette méthode du dialogue de la
concertation c'est ce que nous proposons
c'est ce que j'ai évoqué avec le
président de la république il ya
maintenant un mois on se met autour de
la table on se met autour de la table et
on dialogue
les représentants des trois grandes
associations le gouvernement et les deux
commissions des finances des deux
assemblées
voilà la méthode voilà comment prend les
choses en main voilà comment nous voyons
ce qui peut permettre d'être un vrai
test de la volonté de dialogue du
gouvernement avec les collectivités
territoriales mais aussi le parlement
monsieur président sur une autre
question sur sur la mobilité c'est vrai
qu'il en est beaucoup question ces
derniers temps le mouvement des gilets
jaunes pas fait partie aussi de cette
problématique de la mobilité dans les
territoires tous les territoires ne faut
pas logés à la même enseigne par rapport
aux par rapport au transport collectif
il ya parfois des lignes qui sont
remises en cause pour les veaux c'est
une ligne à ligne saint dié epinal qui
va être suspendue à partir du 22
décembre alors une suspension on sait
quand ça commence on ne sait pas comment
ça ce quand ça se termine
alors comment le sénat un compte peser
sur la prochaine loi mobilité qui vont
entrer en discussions dans les
prochaines semaines
c'est d'abord un sujet sur lequel le
maire de saint dié m'avait saisi au mois
de septembre
david valence dans la rencontre que j'ai
avec les maires des villes moyennes de
ce pays et les deux sénateurs des vosges
daniel grémillet jackie pierre m'avait
eux aussi soumis cet exemple si je peux
me permettre parce que président du
sénat ne connais pas toutes les lignes
dans le détail et leurs dates de
fermeture et de réouverture
mais avec un peu de schizophrénie on est
en train d'augmenter des textes pour
essayer de changer les pratiques du
quotidien des modes de transport moins
de véhicules et en même temps ferme une
ligne du quotidien c'est de la
schizophrénie
alors on va avoir la loi mobilité le
gouvernement a annoncé que la première
lecture aurait lieu au sénat première
dès le mois de janvier est un
signe d'attention mais nous l'avons déjà
dit lors de la réforme de la sncf dont
je rappelle qu'une partie du débouclage
social s'est fait au sénat avec la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire eh bien nous serons
extrêmement attentifs parce que c'est la
logique de ce que nous avons voté dans
la réforme de la sncf et que cette
logique il faut qu'elle se traduise
concrètement pour répondre à un problème
d'aménagement et d'équilibré du
territoire et en même temps un problème
de mobilité du quotidien on voit bien
que dans la décision de taxation
pluriannuel on a vraiment oublier que
70% de ceux qui vont au travail n'ont
pas d'autre choix que d'utiliser leur
véhicule et notamment dans le territoire
qui n'est pas métropolitain
celui qui n'a pas de transport collectif
perco et est donc c'est un enjeu majeur
parce que la france est un tout et nous
devons combattre cette césure que je
sens de plus en plus profonde qui
devient fracture entre des métropoles et
le reste du territoire
merci beaucoup à dominique renaud et
avia vosges tv bas merci dominique
renaud maintenant et bien vu bienvenue
dans la gorge la parole à la salle au
président oui bonjour pascal jalabert
donc une question hier soir le président
a dit j'ai échoué à réconcilier le
peuple des territoires avec ses
dirigeants
et ça dépasserait en personne comment
pensez vous que cette réconciliation
soit possible et comment collectivement
tous les dirigeants peut agir d'abord je
trouve moi qui appelait à une forme
d'écouté d'humilité je m'applique à
moi-même que c'était plutôt positif là
où je suis en désaccord avec le
président c'est de faire un constat sans
essayer de comprendre pourquoi alors
qu'il avait suscité une grande espérance
on en est arrivé là et pourquoi au fond
le président se trouve face aux gilets
jaunes parce qu'il n'a pas été attentif
à ce qu'on appelle les corps
intermédiaires on vient parler de vienne
parler des élus
au travers de la question posée par nos
amis des vosges je pourrais parler des
syndicats des organisations
professionnelles ce matin je recevais
laurent berger et je peux vous dire que
le sentiment du dialogue permanent il
n'existe pas le sentiment d'être court
circuiter mais aussi les médias tout
ceci fait que le président de la
république voulu être dans un espèce de
relation directe mais une relation
directe sans ces corps intermédiaires ça
conduit à se confronter dimanche
ou plutôt samedi à des gilet jaune en
direct savez je crois que plus que
jamais il va falloir qu'on retrouve les
voies du dialogue et en même temps une
espèce d'attitude car quand le président
dit je les comprends je les entends mais
je ne bougerai pas je dis pas que la
solution c'est automatiquement de bouger
mais il faut aussi faire de la pédagogie
on a traité par le mépris ce que disait
le rapporteur général l'an dernier sur
la question de la taxation pluriannuel
donc je crois que l'humilité c'est aussi
le respect notre question dans la salle
bonjour monsieur le président sébastien
côté via grand paris on vous a vu très
impliquée pour soutenir les départements
d'ile-de-france dont certains je parle
des départements de la petite couronne
sont menacés de disparition par
l'exécutif aujourd'hui on n'en parle
plus du tout qu'en est il exactement et
êtes vous toujours dans le même état
d'esprit c'est à dire non à la
suppression des départements de la
petite couronne
je crois au département en occitanie
comme en région ile de france
je crois au département dans le grand
est
comme je crois à la nécessité d'un
département dans la petite couronne
proximité sociale proximité territoriale
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne doit
pas adapté voilà pourquoi
deux départements yvelines autre scène
mutualisent quand les départements du
val de loire ont décidé de mutualiser
leur agence d'ingénierie leur
accompagnement du retour vers l'emploi
nous y sommes favorables et c'est donc
cet état d'esprit auquel nous sommes
favorables quant à l'évolution
métropolitaine vous savez que mon
sentiment a toujours été que la bonne
dimension c'est la région au plan
périmétrique et que la partie la plus
rurale de l'île de france n'entend pas
être en dehors d'un projet métropolitain
voilà pourquoi j'étais en seine-et-marne
la semaine dernière tout comme j'ai été
au mois de septembre dans l'aude ou en
haute garonne parce que je suis aussi
attentifs au rôle et à la place d'un
département francilien que d'un
département présents dans la région
occitanie justement monsieur le
président ce que je vous propose
maintenant c'est de retrouver olivier
roirand avec via occitanie on dirait
quand perpignan
bonjour gérard larcher une question
effectivement depuis perpignan depuis
l'occitanie cette grande région aussi
grande que l'irlande je rappelle 13
départements qui communiquent
régulièrement sur la baisse des
dotations d'état des départements qui
ont la lourde charge de gérer notamment
les aides sociales vous l'avez rappelé
tout à l'heure et le gouvernement la
semaine dernière qui a fait de nouvelles
propositions pour supporter justement
aider ces solidarités 250 millions
d'euros dès 2019 un plan sur trois ans
jusqu'à 323 millions d'euros en 2021
insuffisants ont dit les présidents de
départements à rennes lors de leur
congrès les 8 et 9 novembre dernier mais
ils ont aussi appelé au dialogue alors
vous avez beaucoup parlé dialogue tout à
l'heure dans votre intervention
comment relancer ce dialogue sur
l'aspect structurel des budgets des
départements
un dialogue qui semble être tout de même
au niveau du gouvernement à un dialogue
de sourds avec les départements qui m'a
frappé en étant dans votre région
au mois de septembre c'est d'abord la
diversité de cette région je vais
prendre un seul indicateur
quand on est à toulouse un taux de
chômage de 8,6 quand on est dans les
pyrénées orientales un taux de chômage
de plus de 14% et que face à cela il
faut qu'on puisse apporter un certain
nombre de réponses
ces réponses elles doivent être concrète
et vous appeliez au dialogue mais il ya
des sujets sur lequel il faut que le
gouvernement entame aussi bien avec la
région avec le département qu'avec le
bloc communal un certain nombre de
dialogues je vais prendre l'exemple de
l'aménagement des centres villes et des
centres bourgs nous avions à
l'initiative de jacques mézard un plan
centre ville centre bourg qui a été
renforcée notamment dans le cadre de la
loi logement la loi ayant autour de d'un
rapport du sénat a fait par martial
bourquin et rémy pointereau voilà un
exemple d'une action qu'on peut avoir
sur le territoire avec la région dans
votre région la grande inquiétude c'est
l'éviction des régions des dispositifs
d'apprentissage
est ce que dans les départements qui
connaissent le plus de difficultés
il va se maintenir des cfa et est ce que
les ses fans ne veut pas être uniquement
autour des lieux où il y as
développement économique des moyens
d'aujourd'hui est ce que les plus
pauvres ne veut pas être plus pauvres
demain en matière de formation et ceux
qui sont les mieux dotées encore mieux
dotés demain savez la france c'est tout
à la fois c'est pas que des métropoles
c'est pas non plus qu'un espace rural
nous avons besoin des métropoles nous
avons besoin des villes moyennes
vous êtes dans une région il ya deux
métropoles et vous savez bien que la
situation est assez différente entre les
territoires autour de ces deux
métropoles
et puis il ya la question de la
désertification médicale comment voulez
vous redonner confiance à un territoire
quand aujourd'hui la principale
préoccupation la certain nombre
d'habitants c'est d'avoir un médecin
référent
d'avoir un service d'urgence qui puisse
fonctionner dans lequel on nous annonce
pas qu'on va supprimer un certain nombre
de lignes d'accueil autour des smur des
samu et de l'accueil d'urgence walla les
réalités concrètes que je rencontre sur
le territoire et je vais aller plus loin
en occitanie en haute garonne
le vrai sentiment de différence quand
vous êtes dans le comminges dans une
communauté de communes de 104 communes
et à toulouse il ya un sentiment de
fracture il s'agit pas d'opposer les uns
aux autres nous avons besoin les uns des
autres
nous avons besoin de métropole qui
entraîne mais il faut qu'on soit très
attentifs à ce territoire là c'est
d'ailleurs là où nous voyons le plus de
crispations aujourd'hui le sentiment
d'être abandonnés et je crois que des
politiques ils doivent écouter entendre
mais aussi répondre voilà pourquoi
à la différence du président de la
république moi je pense qu'il faut
bouger parce qu'il ya des jours on peut
avoir tort et c'est pour chacun d'entre
nous est une nécessité
monsieur présent une seconde question
sur cette région que si tu as dit et
notamment le le département de l'aude
eux durement touchée il y à un mois jour
pour jour par de terribles inondations
quinze personnes ont été tuées et 75
blessées des milliers de sinistrés
un territoire dans lequel vous étiez
venu vous l'avez rappelé en septembre
l'eau pour un hommage liées aux
attentats de trêve mais cette fois c'est
une catastrophe naturelle majeure qui a
touché une population qui s'est tournés
naturellement vers les collectivités qui
ont dans ce cas là un rôle
particulièrement important que ce soit
les communes les intercommunalités le
département la région comment
défendez-vous ce rôle majeur des
collectivités locales auprès du
gouvernement même s'il est toujours
évidemment délicat de s'appuyer sur des
faits des aussi dramatique pour mettre à
nouveau coup de pression pour que le
gouvernement n'oublie pas nos
territoires
olivier roirand autour d'eux qu'ils se
sont retrouvés les citoyens le lendemain
des inondations au tour de leur mère
quelle que soit la taille de leur
commune nous venons de commémorer les
trois ans du drame
absolue du terrorisme du bataclan le
lendemain matin j'en ai un souvenir
précis les maires téléphoner au sénat
qu'est ce qui se passe souvenez-vous à
l'époque on ne savait pas bien ce qui se
passait dans le pays et la commune quand
je dis que c'est une petite république
dans la grande
c'est la proximité chacun me met dans la
bouche que les mères seraient apportés
d'engueulades miss ont aussi apporté des
citoyens et donc pour moi ce rôle là il
est irremplaçable
je crois à la solidarité de l'état dans
un département comme l'aude
elle est même indispensable et le
premier ministre comme le président de
la république sont vraiment venu
sincèrement au chevet de ce département
mais concrètement quelques semaines
quelques mois après il va falloir mettre
tout cela en pratique
j'ai eu le maire de trèbes naturellement
pendant cette période et j'ai eu il y à
peu il ya un certain nombre de dépenses
qui aujourd'hui ne sont prises en charge
par personne et qui peuvent mettre en
grande difficulté des communes save et
des dépenses de logistique des équipes
qui viennent déblayer et des des choses
très concrètes et moi je veux aussi les
porter ces choses très concrètes
et cette réalité là c'est dans un
dialogue renouvelé et j'ai demandé à un
certain nombre de maires de l'aude par
leurs sénateurs ou par moi même de me
transmettre
quelles étaient leurs réalités du
quotidien car il y aura des masses
financières importantes mais il yal
immédiate et faut boucler la fin de
l'année dans un budget de fonctionnement
pour une commune et c'est ça aussi un
des rendez vous majeurs de la proximité
entre les politiques les élus et les
citoyens dans une commune
on va remercier vient occitanie pu
revenir oui merci beaucoup et j'ai la
très bons souvenirs de mes deux journaux
merci à rené le président hervé favre la
voix du nord j'avais deux questions
exemple que le président de la
république n'ait pas envie de se mettre
à portée d'engueulades des maires au
prochain congrès la semaine prochaine
qu'est ce que vous lui qu'est ce que
vous lui conseiller est toujours sur la
question des mères la taxe d'habitation
vous nous dites qu'on en est au 6e
scénario est-ce qu'il y en a un qui qui
vous semblent plus le meilleur ou est-ce
que vous rejetez des six à ce moment là
quels sont votre vos préconisations est
la décision pour le congrès des maires
appartient au président de la république
ils sont que ce soit le premier ministre
qui se rendra au congrès des maires
c'est pas une première mais je pense
qu'il faut toujours affronter la lame
mais je ne donne aucun conseil ça assez
bon de côté particuliers d'attachement à
la bretagne et à la navigation dans ces
îles
sur le sujet de la taxe d'habitation est
au fond élargissons de l'autonomie
financière et fiscale des collectivités
locales je reprends tout simplement ce
qu'a dit le président de la république
au congrès des maires l'année dernière
vous savez des paroles restent elles ont
été inscrits
le président de la république dire après
la réforme de la fiscalité il faudra que
les collectivités territoriales et
notamment les mairies et je le cite et
la dimension de l'autonomie financière
et de l'autonomie fiscale à l'orge
j'ai un scénario qui est tout simplement
la proposition numéro 12 que à
l'unanimité le groupe de travail de
révision constitutionnelle du sénat a
fait proposition numéro nous que nous
proposerons et que nous inscrirons dans
la constitution
les collectivités territoriales doivent
avoir une part significative
d'abord d'autonomie financière pas que
significative c'est un principe et une
part significative d'autonomie fiscale
nous ne sommes pas un pays fédéral nous
ne sommes pas là que pour gérer
de l'argent qui serait distribué ou
concédés il faut garder le lien citoyen
service collectivités territoriales il
faut donc conserver une part de capacité
pour les collectivités à lever et à
décider du niveau d'un certain nombre de
taxes
même alain richard qui est à nos
collègues bryant qui a fait avec le
préfet bur un rapport il ya le dire
c'était au mois de septembre qu'il
n'était pas envisageable pour un
département par exemple de n'avoir
qu'une capacité d'adaptation de 2% par
rapport aux taxes que c'était une
manière de dévitalisation financière et
dévitalisation de l'autonomie ce que je
souhaite vraiment c'est qu'on se mette
autour de la table qu'on n'ait pas de
scénario préjugés on fera pas d'accord
sur tout mais au moins qu'on n'est pas
quelque chose qui nous arrive par la
seine en direction des assemblées tout
préparé sans un dialogue préalable avec
les collectivités territoriales
je vous propose maintenant de nous
rendre à saint-etienne avec tl7 et
marianne rsa rédactrice en chef qui a
des questions à vous poser
monsieur le président bonjour d'abord
bienvenue à saint-etienne dans le
département de la loire alors vous
l'avez dire les maires de la loire ne
vont pas bien et en particulier dans les
petites communes rurales plus d'une
vingtaine ont déjà jeté l'épongé depuis
à chaque fois la raison et la même
charge de travail restrictions
budgétaires ils sont épuisés seul face
au poids des normes alors il semble que
vous ayez entendu ce cri d' alerte mais
comment à paris au palais du luxembourg
vous allez les aider ils ont besoin
d'actes monsieur le président et de
financement surtout pas de mots
d'abord dans votre département sans
doute on est dans une situation assez
comparable avec un certain nombre de
départements où les maires prennent la
décision de démissionner parce qu'ils
ont le sentiment de ne plus
prendre réellement part aux décisions
dans le cadre des intercommunalités et
d'un certain nombre de grandes
intercommunalités et c'est d'ailleurs un
des sujets du colloque qui se tiendra
cet après-midi sur le rapport de la
mission en charge du suivi de la mise en
place de la loi sur la nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république
la deuxième des choses c'est qu'il nous
faudra dans le débat sur la fiscalité
locale aussi réexaminer les conditions
des dotations dans votre département
la moitié des communes ont vu leur
dotation globale de fonctionnement
baissé mais c'est le cas dans l'ensemble
du pays et leur apporter une réponse que
leur bloc ne baisseraient pas quand vous
êtes dans une commune du forez je suis
certain que ça beau réjouit pas pour
autant ça vous décourage ça vous
découragez en plus quand vous avez une
campagne de hashtag sur balles aux
thomert alors vous avez la totale d'une
forme de défiance en direction des élus
comment on peut les aider galles c'est
la réforme des dotations globales de
fonctionnement
c'est une réforme du remplacement de la
taxe d'habitation qui leur assure des
ressources et une capacité de décider
d'une partie des taxes ça c'est un point
important c'est une réforme qui n'est
pas automatiquement législatives d'une
pratique un peu différente du
fonctionnement entre communes et
intercommunalités en remettant le
principe de subsidiarité au coeur au
coeur du la relation entre communes et
intercommunalités je prends par exemple
nous avons des intercommunalités ou des
communes de moins de 200 habitants n'ont
plus aucune capacité par exemple à
exercer réglementairement la compétence
voirie espaces verts alors le maire se
dit mais à quoi je sais si dans le
quotidien je ne suis pas en capacité de
répondre à cela
donc pour les maires de la loire
c'est une réponse plus globale qu'il
faut apporter un certain nombre de
collectivités de départements où la
situation est la même
je viens de quitter l'occitanie la haute
garonne a quasiment un record du nombre
de démissions de mer mais surtout et on
en parle très peu
il ya des milliers des milliers de
conseillers municipaux qui ont
démissionné
beaucoup d'entre eux ne sont pas
conseiller communautaire
alors là vraiment ils ont le sentiment
de ne plus servir à rien et pourtant la
trappe des cinq cent mille élus locaux
dans notre pays est indispensable à
cette dimension citoyenne qui nous faut
préserver dans un pays qui se fracturent
qui se replie en communauté quand
j'entends parfois certains propos tenus
par ceux qui ont initié les gilet jaune
je m'inquiète pour la démocratie
je crois à la démocratie représentative
est le premier maillon de la démocratie
représentative
ce sont les conseillers municipaux elle
dans une commune quand on nous dit que
ignorer les formes de démocratie
participative pourquoi pas mais
méfions-nous de la démocratie de la
brutalité
elle pourrait un matin nous conduire à
nous réveiller plus proche de la botte
italienne que la démocratie dont je rêve
autre spécificité de notre département
monsieur le président la préfecture
saint-etienne est à seulement 60
kilomètres de lyon et pourtant les
ligériens peuvent mettre jusqu'à deux
heures pour se rendre dans la capitale
lyonnaise ils n'en peuvent plus le
gouvernement vous le savez certainement
a mis un terme au projet d'autoroute
entre saint-etienne et lyon la fameuse à
alors comment on fait monsieur le
président pour désenclaver ce territoire
cette métropole stéphanoise de quatre
cent mille habitants pour rejoindre lyon
d'abord je constate que c'est une
méthode est dans cette logique de
proximité ce qu'on aura l'occasion de
vous voir d'abord c'est une question de
méthode
du gouvernement le gouvernement a
préféré l'avis du conseil d'orientation
des infrastructures à un débat avec la
région avec le département de la loire
et avec la ville de saint-etienne est au
fond il a pris une décision à sa manière
un peu verticale un peu techno sans
apporter de solution alternative
chacun sait que il peut y avoir des
alternatives à tout projet mais je vous
rappelle qu'il y avait eu un engagement
qui avait été pris précédemment par les
précédents gouvernements dans tout ça a
été balayée sans une vraie concertation
au fond alors nous allons avoir la loi
mobilité au mois de janvier
je peux vous dire que ce sujet sera sur
la table le sujet très précis de là à 45
comme liaison autoroutière d'autres
projets parce qu'on fera pas que de la
théorie sur la mobilité
il faudra qu'on envoie les dimensions
pratique très concrètes
d'autant qu'on aura des contrats de plan
état région qui seront revus à partir de
2020 et que ça se prépare maintenant
merci beaucoup on va retourner vers la
salle maintenant mais bonjour monsieur
le président bruno dive journal sud
ouest
emmanuel macron a regretté hier soir que
de ne pas avoir su réconcilier la france
et ses dirigeants et les français la
base et le sommet a joué savoir si vous
partagez ce diagnostic
et si vous vous saluer cette repentance
j'ai pour partie déjà répondu tout à
l'heure et cette question mais j'aurais
peut-être préciser car portant ça
m'intéresse pas je pense je disais tout
à l'heure que on doit tous faire avoir
notre part d'humilité quand les choses
ne vont pas c'est vrai que la relation
entre le président de la république les
français s'est singulièrement dégradées
ne croyait pas que ça me réjouit parce
que je pense que notre pays a besoin
d'être réformé il a besoin de relever un
certain nombre de défis
et que quelque part la dégradation de
cette confiance nous ouvre des
tentations populistes et que cette
tentation elle pourra avoir une
traduction printemps dans le cadre des
élections européennes qui ne se fera pas
autour des valeurs que nous avons en
partage ce qui nous considérons attachés
à la république
attaché à la vème république mais le
président de la république récolte en ce
moment ce qu'il a semé
coupure avec les corps intermédiaires
voilà pourquoi son itinérance me gelé
nullement critiquer il vaut qu'il renoue
avec les réalités du terrain mme ernoult
et vous n'imaginez pas ce que j'apprends
may 18 départements deux mois en y
prenant le temps en les regardant
au-delà même d'une assemblée en
discutant avec les uns et les autres
j'étais à vichy samedi dans le
bourbonnais et ça n'était pas prévu mais
le secrétaire général des jeunes
agriculteurs vient me faire part de la
situation dans un département l'emploi
agricole ces 6 % de l'emploi lié à la
sécheresse
cc réalité là qu'il faut voir au delà
des réalités des rapports ans j'avais un
rapport comme tout le monde mais le vécu
quotidien de d'agriculteurs dans un
département comme ça si aussi ce qu'il
faut entendre pour éviter que au
printemps prochain
au fond ils disent on a vraiment tout
essayé rien ne marche
pourquoi on ne serait pas d'autres qui
ne porte pas les mêmes valeurs
c'est vraiment ça et de président de la
république il doit avec les élus avec
les syndicats avec des organisations
professionnelles
on voit bien que les organisations
professionnelles comme syndication par
exemple la réforme de l'assurance
chômage se dit mais ce que ça vaut le
coup qu'on négocie parce qu'il paraît
que tout est écrit et en fait tout est
écrit à bercy oui
je crois vraiment me croyez pas obsédé
par bercy bercy
c'est l'héritier de laquelle c'est royal
vous savez c'est leur boulot de défendre
les équilibres financiers
mais il faut se méfier des jacqueries
quand on a une cassette qui n'est qu'une
cassette et qui prend pas en compte la
réalité des hommes et des femmes sur le
terrain je vous propose de poursuivre le
tour de france maintenant d'aller à
brest retrouver bertrand elena qui
dirige tv ou vice et ce que c'est
affronter la lame à brest et bonjour
gérard larcher et bienvenue sur tébéo
étaient des suds
c'était les gens de ton que vous
connaissez bien je sais que évident en
temps dans les parages de l'île de bord
il y avait un gros brouillard sûr que
c'était pas un temps à mettre un
président de sénat dehors
même si vous avez l'habitude de la lame
j'ai un portant là dans le retour de
notre de notre session
vous parliez à l'instant de la cassette
vous êtes expert de la nouvelle organise
des territoires de république
il me semble à la lumière des grandes
difficultés à se les départements il me
semble que cette institution tout cas le
sait départementale ap à bout de souffle
d'un point du ter ont parlé de la
faillite ou de la case ift de certains
départements
je veux savoir quelle était votre
sentiment là tu nous disais tout à
l'heure
e pour vous le périmètre le plus
pertinent c'était la région vous parliez
du grand paris mais est ce que on peut
pas aider les gens de bercy dans les
équations difficile coûts extrêmement
lourd de la décentration en avançant
comme l'avait fait nicolas sarkozy sur
la la commande dans la perspective
suppression enfin des départements
tu désolé cas il ya un peu de brouillard
sur l'île de batz ça n'arrive jamais
parce que chez vous il fait toujours
beau plusieurs fois par jour
je voudrais dire c'est que je crois au
département il est la proximité sociale
il est la proximité territoriale
je vais prendre un exemple est-ce qu'on
peut gérer l'aide sociale à l'enfance
totalement depuis rennes est-ce qu'on
peut gérer les allocations sociales
le retour vers l'emploi le rsa dans
l'ariège uniquement de toulouse est-ce
qu'on peut dans les ardennes territoire
qui connaît une grande pauvreté lutter
contre la pauvreté
depuis strasbourg nous avons besoin de
cette proximité là et le département est
un relais de proximité et si les
départements pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux connaissent de grandes
difficultés
c'est aussi que les gouvernements ça n'a
pas commencé sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande
pas plus que sous ce quinquennat là ils
ont progressivement eu un reste à charge
qui n'a cessé de croître en matière
d'allocations sociales individuelles et
aujourd'hui pour des mineurs étrangers
non accompagnés
nous donc quitter nos amis d'occitanie
est-ce que vous mesurez aujourd'hui la
réalité du passage de mineurs étrangers
non accompagnés à hendaye ou dans les
pyrénées orientales
quand le président de l'adf président du
département de charente-maritime le
brocarde parfois le plus violemment
modéré d'entre nous peut-être numéro
deux dans le violemment modéré le plus
violemment de les modérer dit à votre
confrère sud ouest
quand j'en accueillait 10 par semaine
j'en ai 14 par jour ouvrable aujourd'hui
et vous croyez que ça n'a pas des
conséquences quand dans un département
comme à lumbres et loire
le montant du coût des mineurs étrangers
non accompagnés est devenu très
supérieur à la capacité qu'a un
département de
ôtez d'accompagner des projets et
notamment des projets d'équipement des
communes et les intercommunalités
d'indre et loire département fait son
devoir
son devoir social alors on peut dire
qu'on l'a fixiez notre notre rôle est le
rôle de l'exécutif c'est de redonner un
peu d'oxygène à ces départements la
voilà pourquoi quand dominique bussereau
dit on prend l'aide mais ça n'est qu'un
acompte
il faut régler les problèmes au fond je
partage son analyse et le sénat
soutiendra cette démarche
merci beaucoup bertrand le néna on va
retrouver maintenant la salle avec vos
questions bonjour s'est mêlé aux agences
à lpg vous interroger sur un territoire
un peu plus éloignés qui est la nouvelle
calédonie qui a voté il ya 11 jours pour
son maintien dans la france mais dans
des proportions nettement moins
importante que ce qu'on prédisait
s'ouvre donc une période qui peut
aboutir à deux nouveaux référendums
avec toutes les instabilités politiques
qu'on peut supposer vous connaissez bien
le territoire vous connaissez bien cette
problématique comment vous même et les
sénats pouvez vous accompagner la
nouvelle calédonie dans ces quatre
années qui s'annoncent
tout d'abord je dois dire que je dis
respect quand 80% de la population
participe à référendum
c'est donc l'ensemble des
néo-calédoniens ac sont exprimés
le résultat on le connaît une majorité
d'entre eux ont choisi de rester dans la
république française en étant il ya des
accords et pendant trente ans tous les
gouvernements quelle que soit leur
sensibilité on respecter ces accords ne
l'oublions pas voulu par deux hommes qui
se sont tendu la main
jean marie tjibaou et jacques lafleur
avec un premier ministre avec lequel
j'avais échangé à partir en nouvelle
calédonie michel rocard et tous les
gouvernements ont respecté cela il
appartient donc au gouvernement
parlement mais aussi à l'ensemble des
forces politiques
social de nouvelle calédonie la de
construire et d'imaginer l'avenir est ce
qu'on s'en tient à l'accord tel qu'il
existe dans ce cas là il doit être
respecté
ou est ce qu'on peut imaginer pour
éviter le risque de paralysie
parce que la paralysie politique peut
entraîner une paralysie économique et
avoir des conséquences sociales
importantes
en tous les cas pour moi le dossier de
la nouvelle calédonie c'est quand même
un dossier un peu exemplaire dans quel
autre endroit à pays à respecter pendant
30 ans je parle de la france sa parole
et les calédoniens dans leur diversité
dossier respecter or il ya eu des
tensions mais c'est normal donc
aujourd'hui le sénat veut être un
facilitateur du dialogue et peut-être de
solutions qui devront être imaginées par
l'ensemble des forces politiques
merci monsieur le président justement je
vais vous donner la parole juste après
si vous voulez bien à l'asie excusez moi
vous avez robert à hervé nouvelle
calédonie monsieur le président pour
compléter la question et la réponse que
vous avez apporté à samuel ribot mon
confrère
qu'est ce que vous pensez est-ce que
vous soutenez la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle de votre collègue
pierre frogier est ce que ça vous paraît
être le bon chemin elle est sur la table
elle a le mérite d'exister il faut voir
ce que l'ensemble des partenaires
politiques et des forces politiques
proposent je crois que je recevrai les
maires de nouvelle calédonie lundi nous
aurons l'occasion de débattre et
d'échanger mois par nature j'ai vite la
verticalité dans mes décisions en voyez
ce que j'ai parfois reprocher je vais
donc entendre les maires de nouvelle
calédonie
quelle que soit leur sensibilité et j'ai
toujours reçu les deux associations de
maires ensemble parce que ils ont aussi
cette sensibilité-là du quotidien même
si la statue des communes en nouvelle
calédonie est un peu différent du statut
sur l'ensemble du territoire de la
république
et puis ensuite je reverrai pierre
frogier je reverrai aussi l'ensemble des
forces politiques qui ont appelé pour
certains à voter non pour d'autres à
voter oui parce que je pense que si on a
des a priori alors le dialogue a du mal
à se renouveler
mais la proposition de pierre frogier
est sur la table elle a le mérite
d'avoir été fait avant le résultat du
référendum
elle mérite donc d'être examinée
respectez partagé après la nouvelle
calédonie je vous propose de retrouver
quatre lignes bilasco pet qui est la
rédactrice en chef devient à tv à fort
de france
c'est maintenant pour moi jordanie c'est
maintenant pour moi bonjour bonjour
gérard larcher je suis très heureuse de
vous interroger depuis la martinique
c'est un territoire que vous connaissez
il ya beaucoup de l'archer on remarque
d'amérique
on a dû comprendre votre expression et
pour couronner le tout oui je sais je
sais et et on a même un chez nous un
morne qui porte le nom de mon marché
donc vous vous connaissez bien la
martinique et et gérard larcher alors
augmentation de la fiscalité sur le rhum
martiniquais qui est le seul roma océans
au monde
rameau du plafond de l'abattement de 30%
jusqu alors accordé aux contribuables
ultramarins deux exemples parmi d'autres
de la volonté du gouvernement de mettre
fin à certains avantages dont
bénéficient nos territoires pour
accompagner le développement et combler
des inégalités de développement qui sont
réels et ces mesures là vont fragiliser
nos économies qui sont déjà précaire
alors tout en revendiquant son
attachement à nos régions on a le
sentiment que le gouvernement nous
enlève des leviers importants de
développement
quelle est la position du sénat sur le
sujet
d'abord il est vrai que la question des
outre-mer nécessite des réponses
spécifiques et qu'on ne peut pas après
avoir
construit un certain nombre de villes
levier à caractère d'investissement de
levier fiscaux les retirer brutalement
parce que pour bien connaître la
martinique mais on pourrait en dire
autant d'autres îles de la caraïbe
en martinique la question du travail de
l'emploi et du chômage des jeunes reste
une vraie préoccupation pour la cohésion
de notre pays
peut-être sur la question du rhum qui
est un exemple
d'abord ce sont des milliers d'emplois
2000 direct mais beaucoup plus indirecte
c'est 20 % de la valeur ajoutée de la
branche agroalimentaire dans son
ensemble on n'est pas sur quelque chose
de marginal c'est aussi une image vous
êtes le seul aoc aop qui existent dans
le monde pour leurs hommes alors il ya
d'abord eu le combat du sénat vous le
savez hier sénatrice avec le soutien de
l'ensemble des sénateurs quasiment
catherine conconne s'est battu comme une
martiniquaise décidé pour obtenir le
gouvernement a transigé à 6 années six
années ça nous donne le temps de
réexaminer
tout cela est donc une réponse a été
portée par le sénat j'espère que le
moment venu l'assemblée nationale sera
attentive à cette préoccupation en même
temps c'est vrai lutter contre les
addictions à l'alcool c'est aussi un
sujet mais on s'apercevait que le
produit des taxes prélevées n'allait pas
du tout à la prévention des addictions
un peu comme pour le carburant c'est un
peu comme pour le carburant les taxes
qui ne vont pas ou vous aujourd'hui à
plus de dotations en matière de
transition écologique
il ya un engagement de la ministre qui a
été prise hier nous le verrons mais en
tous les cas cette part de combat il
était elle a été gagnée au sénat hier en
même temps en allant plus avant je
rencontrerai bientôt des représentants
des entreprises
de martinique je crois qu'il est
important de se reposer la question
c'est le travail de notre délégation aux
outre-mer quelle approche on a fiscal
quelle approche on a au plan du
développement économique pour la
martinique la guadeloupe la guyane la
réunion c'est aussi des sujets qui sont
sur la table
merci monsieur le président pour cette
réponse vous avez également parlé tout à
l'heure d'environnement et vous le savez
nos territoires paient un lourd tribut
aux changements climatiques et nous
sommes confrontés depuis plusieurs
années maintenant au problème crucial
des sargasses les mairies les
collectivités locales sont en première
ligne face à ce problème parce que c'est
elle qui au quotidien voit arriver les
sargasses sur les plages doivent faire
face à la détresse des habitants démunis
face aux problèmes des commerçants qui
aussi en pâtissent l'activité
touristique est fortement pénalisée par
ce problème des sargasses le
gouvernement s'est engagé sur 10
millions d'euros sur deux ans pour la
martinique et la guadeloupe c'est
nettement insuffisant
est ce qu'on peut espérer un
accompagnement du sénat sur la demande
de reconnaissance de catastrophe
naturelle pour ce problème
demande qui est pour l'instant rejeté en
bloc par le président de la république
qui est venu récemment sur nos
territoires et qui s'est exprimé sur le
sujet la question des sargasses je fais
peut-être l'expliqué un peu pour
l'ensemble de nos téléspectateurs de
métropole pour qu'il comprenne bien
jj des algues vertes eh bien ça n'est
pas tout à fait la même chose mais c'est
quand même comparable
et c'est pour l'économie touristique
pour l'économie de la pêche
un véritable défi que en quelque sorte
cet échouage massif lié on le dit à la
fois à des phénomènes tellurique liées à
la déforestation notamment en amérique
du sud et au réchauffement climatique
notre délégation aux autres maires a
conclu dans un rapport à deux choses il
faut soutenir encourager tout ce qui est
en matière de recherche scientifique
pour essayer de comprendre ce phénomène
est donc le maîtriser deuxième des
choses
vous savez que la délégation de
l'outre-mer a insisté pour que la
situation de catastrophe naturelle soit
prise en compte par l'exécutif donc le
sénat sur ce sujet s'est clairement
positionné en même temps les moyens et
nous allons voir le rapport de dominique
théophile qui lui est un député un
sénateur de la guadeloupe dans quelques
semaines pour faire les propositions
nous sénat avec l'assemblée nationale où
l'espérons pourra essayer de progresser
parce que se posent des questions comme
par exemple qu'est ce qu'on fait une
fois collectés de l'objet de la collecte
et de l'échouage est ce qu'on en fait du
compost est ce qu'on en fait un élément
énergétique mais comme c'est moi
régulier que les algues vertes il ya des
vrais sujets qui ont été posées sur ce
dossier en tous les cas c'est un sujet
présent dans les préoccupations du sénat
je peux l'assurer à nos compatriotes de
martinique prix encore pas simplement
par les élus de la martinique de la
guadeloupe mais par l'ensemble des élus
et par le président du sénat il doit
dire michel magras qui préside notre
délégation à l'outre-mer je vous renvoie
un rapport vous y retrouverez toutes les
préoccupations nous portons on va
remercier l'ensemble des chaînes de
télévision locales qui sont d'abord vous
remercier hans de presse et vous
féliciter parce que je vois à la fois
qu'il ya quelque part une forme de
prouesse technique remercier pour le
décalage horaire nous habille de la
martinique particulièrement
vraiment c'était extrêmement sympathique
et symbolique que vous soyez présents
parce que le sénat c'est l'assemblée des
territoires mais de tous les territoires
de tous les territoires je me permets
d'insister sûr ce point pas simplement
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de l'arche et à
la martinique
parce que c'est aussi ça la république
la république c'est tout à la fois je le
rappelle ces mots du général de gaulle
donc merci à vos confrères
merci à la presse quotidienne régionale
et s'il reste une question je suis à
disposition
et même si la pendule vient de sonner
l'heure et c'est moins compliqué leur
cas big ben ce midi pour des raisons
break site bon voilà oui le président
oui le président république a aussi
lierre attention vous ne vous manipulent
il apparaît de récupération du moment de
gilet jaune
pensez vous que cette récupération peut
être dangereuse et inutile
comment l'éviter de façon assez urgente
sujet la berre d'abord moi je n'en
serais pas pour que les choses soient
claires mon rôle me semble-t-il ma place
c'est de veiller à ce qu'on reprenne la
proposition du sénat qui je le rappelle
a été de revenir un examen annuel les
conditions d'aujourd'hui pas remplies et
donc à suspendre les deux milliards 8 de
taxation en plus ce qui pèserait en 2019
et je rappelle
que cette taxation aujourd'hui
n'augmente nullement les crédits de
transition écologique
en fait on a habillé en vert une taxe
sans lui donner sans lui donner
j'allais dire la réalité concrète on va
même diminués sais pas si vous le savez
puisque les fenêtres isolantes vont être
retirés du crédit d'impôt mais je donne
cet exemple parce que ça va être en
centaines de millions la différence donc
qu'on n'utilise pas l'argument vert pour
une taxe qui va renflouer les caisses de
l'état
en plus on a un problème on taxe plus
lent des taxes et je vous parle pas de
la complexité de cette taxation
j'ai été ministre du travail à un moment
où ceux-ci envolée je me souviens
premier ministre était dominique de
villepin on a inventé les trucs quand
jamais marché je pense que la vraie
formule c'est celle que propose la
commission des finances du sénat que
l'annonceur 2017 c'est pas une surprise
et c'est autour de ça je vais mobiliser
mais naturellement mais est ce que il ne
faut pas écouter entendre la colère des
français
est ce qu'il faut sans couper moi
j'écoute j'entends j'écoutais j'entends
et je vois et qu'au delà de la sphère
des carburants et à comment vous dire un
sentiment notamment des classes moyennes
sentiment des classes moyennes que
vraiment ça pèse sur eux que ça pèse
vraiment sur va avoir la csg dans
prochain un milliard c'est que tu crois
en plus on a des tas qui peuvent vous
sembler anodine sur l'assurance
emprunteur plus 100 millions se prépare
une nouvelle taxation au nom de
l'environnement
mais at-elle été analysés préparé sur
les ordures ménagères
tout ça va peser et on peut pas parler
de cette taxation tant qu'on n'a pas
résolu le problème du devenir du
remplacement de la taxe d'habitation qui
est basée sur le foncier bâti
sachant qu'une partie des taxes sont
basés sur le foncier bâti et que dans
certaines simulations on arrive à des
addicts dans certains endroits pour
certains types de propriétés qui sont
confiscatoire donc je crois que c'est
tout ça qui s'exprime et avec le
sentiment que au fond serait en train de
se créer de france hier je recevais les
maires des villes moyennes
je reçois à peu près tous les trois
semaines sept huit maires de villes
moyennes de ce pays pour essayer de
comprendre ce qu'ils ne sont pas dans
les attractions métropolitaine pour
essayer de comprendre quelques temps je
recevais aussi bien le maire de béthune
hier le maire de sens de montauban je
parlais du maire de saint dié tout à
l'heure mais qu'est ce qu'ils regardent
aujourd'hui ils ont eu aussi le
sentiment qu'ils ont une responsabilité
vis-à-vis de leur territoire mais
quelque part le système vertical le
système normatif la contractualisation
financière qui n'a pas fait de vraies
différences entre les réalités des
territoires
c'est une manière je n'ai pas encore
prononcé ce mot de recentralisation de
reconcentration du pouvoir moi je crois
qu'on doit au contraire aborder une
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
car avec le président de la république
ma chouette qu'on dresse ce pays il ya
des réformes qu'il faut faire et il faut
parfois de la pédagogie
parce que ce n'est pas simple à faire
mais je crois vraiment que c'est un défi
sur lequel nous pourrions nous retrouver
comme on s'est retrouvé sur la loi
logement
l'opposition qui ne débouchent pas à un
moment entre les uns et les autres sur
une solution qui nous permette de
converger sur un certain nombre de
points
c'est assez stérile et nous sommes face
à des défis très importants
préc site j'espère que madame mais va
réussir
mais si je suis à toulouse
et si j'ai pas d'accord sur les normes
je sais plus monter les ailes de l'a350
ou le dit pendant des mois ce sera pas
sans conséquences économiques et
sociales
la question migratoire si on n'a pas le
courage de la regarder en face c'est ce
que nous allons faire d'ailleurs ici au
sénat au printemps avec les sénats
africain eh bien je crains qu'il n'y ait
des modes d'expression qui sortent des
valeurs que nous avons en partage
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
vous remerciant les uns et les autres
d'être venu partager cette matinée
j'aurais vraiment remercier cyril
viguier public sénat michel cymes et et
et d'autres encore
et les techniciens permettez-moi
d'associer des équipes du sénat parce
que c'était pour eux une une première
avec toujours l'angoissé ce que ça va
marcher ça marche toujours
bravo bravo et et et merci à tous et
merci je redis que je crois rôle
vraiment des médias de la presse
quotidienne régionale pour la cohésion
du territoire
c'est pas les propos pour vous faire
plaisir j'y crois profondément
ce que je crois que le territoire c'est
la république
merci beaucoup voilà pour cette
conférence de presse du président du
sénat qui s'est donc exprimé devant la
presse quotidienne régionale ainsi que
les télévisions locales conférence de
presse que vous avez pu suivre dans son
intégralité et en direct sur l'antenne
de public sénat
l'occasion quelques jours après le
congrès de l'assemblée des départements
de france et avant celui des maires de
revenir pour gérard larcher sur le
malaise profond des territoires et
gérard larcher a notamment imputé le
divorce qui existe aujourd'hui entre les
territoires et l'exécutif au manque de
pédagogie du gouvernement mais aussi et
surtout au manque d'attention accordée
aux corps intermédiaires par l'exécutif
il a été interrogé sur un certain nombre
de sujets précis notamment la taxe
d'habitation
nous en sommes au sixième de scénarios
de remplacement de la taxe d'habitation
s'est il exclamé
il s'est également exprimé sur le mouv
monde et gilet jaune et sur la hausse de
la taxe sur les carburants
le président du sénat a rappelé que la
majorité sénatoriale s'était opposé à
plurien annuel cela dès l'année dernière
lors de l'examen du budget une position
qu'elle continue à soutenir aujourd'hui
c'est même la contre proposition du
sénat pour calmer la colère des gilets
jaunes
il a enfin rappelé que plus globalement
le sénat se saisirait de la loi mobilité
dès janvier prochain en première lecture
sinon et bien vous aurez noté la
diversité des préoccupations des
territoires qui se sont exprimés ce
matin de l'a45 le projet d'autoroute
abandonné entre lyon et saint-etienne à
la situation de l'aude cela en passant
par le problème des sargasses ces algues
toxiques véritable fléau aux antilles
enfin et bien noté les mots de gérard
larcher à l'adresse des mères à la
veille du congrès des maires et cet
avertissement à emmanuel macron qui
n'assistera pas à l'événement il faut
toujours affronter la lame à méditer
donc pour le président de la république
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi vous pouvez
retrouver tous nos programmes sur
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]
non